قليل اتوجه الى فادي منصور من البنتاجون ل
يطلعنا على تفاصيل اكثر عما جاء في كلام
الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن نعم سوف نترجم بيان الرئيس بايدن
لفائده مشاهدي الجزيره قال ف انه اليوم
وبتوجيه مني قامت القوات الامريكيه
بالتعاون مع القوات البريطانيه وبدعم من
كل من استراليا والبحرين وكندا وهولندا
بتوجيه ضربات بنجاح ضد
مواقع عدد من المواقع في اليمن يستخدمها
متمردو الحوثيين من اجل تعريض حريه
الملاحه للخطر في واحده من اكثر الممرات
المائيه حيويه في العالم الرئيس بايدن
تابع في بيانه بان هذه الضربات هي رد
مباشر على الهجمات الحوثيه غير المسبوقه
على على مساله الملاحه البحريه والسفن
الملاحيه البحريه في البحر الاحمر بما فيه
استخدام الصواريخ البالستيه المضاده للسفن
للمره الاولى في التاريخ في اشاره الى
استخدامها من قبل انصار الله الحوثيين
واضاف الرئيس بايدن في بيانه بان هذه
الهجمات
عرضت حياه الافراد الامريكيين للخطر
بالاضافه الى حياه البحاره المدنيين
بالاضافه الى شركاء الولايات المتحده
وهددت التجاره وهددت ايضا حريه الملاحه
واشار الرئيس بايدن الى ان اكثر من 50
دوله تاثرت ب 27 هجوما على الملاحه ملاحه
الشحن الدولي واضاف ان الطواقم من اكثر من
20 بلدا تعرضوا للتهديدات او جرى اتخاذهم
كرهائن في عمليات قرصنه حسب تعبيره واضاف
الرئيس بايدن في بيانه ان اكثر من 2000
سفينه اضطرت وفرض عليها ان تحول الالاف ان
تحول الالاف من الاميال في مسارها لكي
تتجنب البحر الاحمر مما قد يسبب اسابيع من
التاخير في ايصال المواد والبضائع من خلال
الشحن البحري واضاف انه في التاسع من
يناير الحالي قام الحوثيون بشن اكبر هجوم
لهم حتى تاريخه مباشره على السفن
الامريكيه هذه المره الاولى التي تقر
الاداره الامريكيه بان سفنها الحربيه
تعرضت للهجوم وهذا هو الهجوم الذي كان
وصفه البنتاجون في التاسع من يناير بانه
هجوم معقد استخدمت فيه المسيرات صواريخ
كروز مضاده للسفن وصاروخ بالستي واحد
مضاده للسفن تصدت لها ثلاث مدمرات امريكيه
وسفينه حربيه بريطانيه وبالتالي الرئيس
بايدن للمره الاولى يعلن بان السفن
الحربيه الامريكيه كانت المستهدفه في هجوم
التاسع من يناير يضيف الرئيس الامريكي في
بيانه بان رد المجتمع الدولي على هذه
الهجمات
المتهوره كان متحدا وموحدا وحازما ويضيف
الرئيس انه الشهر الماضي الولايات المتحده
اطلقت عمليه حارس الازدهار اي العمليه
التي اعلنت عنها الولايات المتحده في الثم
عش من ديسمبر وتشارك فيها نحو 20 دوله حتى
هذه اللحظه واضاف بايدن ان هذا التحالف من
اكثر من 20 دوله ملتزم بالدفاع عن الشحن
البحري الدولي وعن ردع هجمات الحوثيين في
البحر الاحمر يكمل الرئيس الامريكي اننا
ايضا انضممنا وشاركنا اكثر من 40 دوله في
ادانه والتنديد بتهديدات الحوثيين الاسبوع
الماضي وان وا
اصدرنا تحذيرا لا لبس فيه
للمتمرد الحوثيين وفق تعبير الرئيس بايدن
بانه سوف يكون هناك عواقب اذا لم تتوقف
هجماتهم ويضيف الرئيس الامريكي ويوم امس
اي في اشاره هنا في توقيت واشنطن ليوم
الاربعاء الامم المتحده مجلس الامن الدولي
التابع للامم المتحده مرر قرارا يطالب
الحوثيين بانهاء هجماتهم على السفن
التجاريه و في منطقه البحر الاحمر ويختم
الرئيس الامريكي في تناوله للضربات على
مواقع انصار الله الحوثيين في اليمن ان
الضربات الاجراء راءات الدفاعيه اليوم
تاتي بعد جهود وحمله دبلوماسيه
مكثفه وبعد تصعيد من قبل متمردي الحوثيين
هجماتهم على السفن التجاريه يقول الرئيس
بايدن في بيانه هذه الضربات المحدده وال
موجهه هي رساله واضحه بان الولايات
المتحده وشركائها لن تتسا مح مع اي هجمات
على افرادها وقواتها ولن تسمح باجراءات
عدائيه تهدد حريه الملاحه في واحد من اهم
والاكثر حيويه ممرات البحريه في العالم في
اشاره الى البحر الاحمر ختاما يقول الرئيس
بايدن لن اتردد بتوجيه اوامر باجراءات
اضافيه لحمايه شعبنا وحر يه
التجاره العالميه اذا رايت ضروره لذلك نعم
هذا هو بيان الرئيس بايدن شكرا جزيلا لك
فادي منصور بالتاكيد تبقى معنا شكرا ترجمت
لنا
مباشره ما جاء في هذه في هذا الخطاب وهذه
التصريحات للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن والتي
ربما